ترادوا ايران في العراق في مرمى نيران
طهران في بلده كوريا شمال العراق تظهر هذه
الصور الاضرار التي لحقت بهذه القاعده
التابعه للحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض والناجمه عن الهجمات
الاخيره التي شنتها ايران بحسب الذي يؤكد
ان القصف طال كذلك بنايه سكنيه بالقرب من
مقرها
بكثير كان الاطفال والعائلات خائفين
للغايه صرنا نعيش على خوف دائما من التعرض
للقتل هذه المره استهدف ايضا المدرسه
وبداخلها الاطفال
استهدفوا المدنيين
الايراني ضربات ضد الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني او جماعات اخرى في
كردستان العراق الحكومه الايرانيه تصف هذه
الفصائل بالارهابيين متهمه اياها اضطرابات
المدنيه الحاصله في بلادها وتهريبها اسلحه
من العراق
حزب الله على الاطلاق على قيامنا بتهريب
اسلحه من العراق الى ايران في الواقع انها
كذبه اختلقها النظام الايراني لاخفاء
الحقيقه عن الناس النظام هو الارهابي
وحزبنا كندا دائما سلميا
الحزب الديمقراطي والكردستاني الايراني
كبير